طيب خبرنا الجي يمكن يبدو عادي بس تفاصيله
فعلا عجيبه السلطات الاندونيسيه بتحارب
التسول بس مو هذا هو العجيب في الخبر اكيد
العجيب هو تكمله العنوان السلطات
الاندونيسيه قالت انه بتحارب التسول
اونلاين اوف لاين وهنا عاد السؤال التسول
الاوف لاين هذا عارفينه في الشوارع فلماكن
العامه وغيرها بس ايش هذا التسول اون لاين
اتضح يا جماعه انه في ترند في اندونيسيا
والترند احنا قررنا نسميه التسول في زمن
تيك توك والترند ببساطه هو انه مواطنين
بيفتحوا لايفات على تيك توك وبيبداوا
يطلبوا من الناس اللي بيتفرجوا عليهم انهم
يبعتوا لهم جوائز الجوائز هذه ميزه يعني
ما يعرف ولو فاتح لايف الناس ممكن تبعث لك
هدايا وهذه الهدايا بتتحول فلوس
[موسيقى]
ريماس دنيا
الموضوع ما كبر ودخلت فيه السلطات الا لما
دخلوا في مسنين وما صار الموضوع بس ناس
جالسه وبتترجل متابعين انه يبعتوا لهم
هدايا لا الموضوع صار انه بيعرضوا على
المتابعين انه يعملوا تصرفات عجيبه مقابل
الهدايا وابرز المطالب هي انه يستحموا
بالطين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]